hello i'm greg sadler i am a philosopher
by trade and also by inclination so i
have a lot of thoughts about happiness
and i was very interested to become part
of happiness happens month
as a happiness ambassador
and one of the things that they have on
their site that i thought was
particularly
interesting and for me thought provoking
was their typology of 31
types of happiness and when i read
through their their list and looked at
their badges you'll see a lot of them
replicated
in this video
i thought to myself well some of those
aren't really happiness but then as i
thought more well if you have an
encompassing
you know
intentionally ambiguous conception of
happiness then you can kind of roll them
all into one but i thought what would be
fun certainly for me as i was wrapping
my head around this and perhaps for you
the viewer said you know whether you've
given a lot of thought to this or not
would be to look at those 31 types of
happiness and see if we can
classify them a little bit further and
say which ones are
you know
more important and
how are they actually components or
parts or or
uh contributors to happiness so what i
went through and i just did a
pretty
simple list i realized that a lot of
them
are actually emotional or mood what we
might call modalities types of emotions
that are associated with happiness in
some people's conceptions
so i'm going to talk about those first
and then there's some that are what i
would call more action or attitude or
cognitive oriented
qualities of a person when we're naming
something like
you know this person is this sort of
person and not just talking about their
emotions
then there's a
smaller group that actually name
what i would call activities or or
comportments and then there's some that
seem to be
you know more along the lines of what
happens to you
and then there's a few
that are so big picture broad stuff
that i don't want to reduce them to buzz
words i want to say they have to be in
their their own sort of super categories
and those would actually be love
and spiritual and i'll talk about those
at the end so let's talk about first
emotional modalities
we have a whole bunch of
emotion words or mood words being thrown
in there and how are these connected
with happiness some of them are
no-brainers joyful okay so if you're
joyful you're
most likely going to be somebody that we
would call
happy or
hopeful i think that hope and happiness
are closely related
um amused often times we'll say i'm
happy when we are are being amused and
we're actually going to talk about humor
as another
badge another type a little bit later
but being amused you know enjoying a
game watching a show that's funny or a
clip
seeing cats playing on you know a cat
person watching kittens play that's
amusement
um what about other ones let's let's
look at some of these modalities
anticipation
is anticipation
part of happiness it really depends on
what you're anticipating doesn't it
because if you're anticipating getting
an irs audit
you're not happy right
on the other hand if you're anticipating
a nice birthday cake on your birthday
now you are happy if you're anticipating
a surprise party when you're agoraphobic
and don't want all these people shoved
in your living room
now you're unhappy you know we could go
down the list anticipation is kind of
an interesting one to put in there there
is definitely a positive sort of
anticipation but um not always same with
awestruck you know
um
we can be awestruck and and that can be
part of happiness for us but you know or
can also be one
little shade away from terror
as well
and you know somebody might say well the
way i define it is this i'm just talking
about the way it's used in literature
you know throughout all of our history
so awestruck is an interesting one as
well confident
is happiness
and confidence
is there a necessary connection between
them
certainly when we are
happy in a broad
uh eudaimonistic sense we are
confident say about the future
but
sometimes you can you know people can be
happy without being confident
and not all confidence is uh necessarily
happy i guess if if confidence refers to
like one's own
capacities to deal with what's going to
come up or whether things are good
things are coming along its way
then maybe that's tied in with happiness
mellow that's an interesting one
does that name a mood i think that you
could say that it does and
that's a good thing to point out because
oftentimes we think of happiness in very
activistic terms or very like i'm joyful
i'm happy
and you know what is the kind of
happiness that we have and we're just
hanging out with old friends
or nobody else is in the room we've come
in from the rain
taking off the wet clothes put on some
nice you know fresh dry clothes and
we're just sitting in front of the fire
maybe reading a book or you know petting
the dog or the cat
enjoying a mug of coffee or cocoa or a
beer
we're just being melt
what about you know when people go to
listen to a band in a nice beautiful
environment and nothing special is
happening but they're happy that that
would be
that mellowness right
it's relieved
that's an interesting one because when
you're relieved it's because something
bad was on the horizon or something bad
was already here and now you remove that
and it's sort of like when you take off
ankle weights now you can jump a lot
higher you can run a lot faster
relieved works like that is it really a
happiness
i would say yes it is but it's one
that's dependent on the removal of some
sort of obstacle some sort of irritant
some something that's been bothering you
thankful gratitude is something that we
know is closely connected with happiness
by the way it wasn't the positive
psychology people who figured this out
they just happened to market that idea
it's actually
you know people like cicero
or aristotle or augustine great thinkers
in the past who had this figured out
and people have been talking about this
all the way up to the present including
you know
great philosophers like adrian pepperzak
who has entire entire chapters devoted
to in his his ethical works
now the one that i put off till last
about these moods
is nostalgic and i think that this one
is very interesting because when we talk
about nostalgia
we're talking about something that's
bittersweet for most people
you are nostalgic about what was and
what was valuable but is now no longer
here
and you feel it's loss
but in the nostalgia you also have some
sort of connection to its presence
how is that connected with happiness how
is that happiness some of us you know
really enjoy
these bittersweet nostalgic moments you
see them pouring over their old
photographs
and talking with you know family members
or friends but do you remember the time
when we
do you remember how that dog used to
have was do you remember that trip and
the way that the ocean was at that time
we can even be nostalgic for what we've
never experienced that's that's the
power of literature
and poetry so those are all emotional
modalities i think that's one very
interesting subset of the types of
happiness
um not ones that if i were to put
together the list myself i would have
necessarily associated with it but you
know when you put them out there and
when you put a little bit of thought
into it i think you can see why they're
there
now let's talk about qualities
some of these are more longer term
dispositional kinds of things
and some of these i think are more
ephemeral or situational
so they have things in here like
balanced
i think that's probably a good one
now here we start getting into
an interesting
issue when we're talking about these
types of happiness to or what we're
talking about
expressions of happiness
subdivisions of happiness
the things that make us happy
the objects of happiness
all of these all rolled up in one
think about this with respect to balance
now a happy person is probably going to
be a little bit better at balancing
their life in terms of you know we talk
about for example about work-life
balance right or um balancing
relationships so you don't just you know
hang out you know you meet somebody you
like you don't just suddenly lose all
your friends right all those sorts of
things to be balanced
a happy person is probably going to be
better at doing that
but doesn't balance itself also
contribute to or conduce to
happiness
is balance itself something that we can
look at as an expression of happiness
i mean if you were going to ask me what
does a happy person look like
balanced is not the first thing that
would come to mind
but it does seem to have some sort of
relation there
so that's quite interesting to think
about
cheerful this one i think is very easy
to associate with happiness that makes
perfect sense we probably don't need to
dwell on it except to say that
cheerfulness is a disposition but it's
also a choice you know the people who
are cheerful who smile at you on the
street it could be because they just
they're sanguine types and they just do
that or it could be because they're
actually
they see you and they can see that
you're a little bit down so i can help
that person out a little bit not not
that much but i'll smile for them
it's not so much smiling because they're
happy it's smiling to produce
happiness uh content being content with
what you have that that is in many
theories of happiness that's a
centerpiece of it
honorable
now that's not one that i would have
said is a type of happiness
but it does make sense
honor or respect or
you know esteem there's a lot of
different words for it that we use
being being held to be
valuable a good person by other people
is important to us
now
to be honorable doesn't just mean to
have that it means to actually be the
type of person who deserves that
who earns them
and
that is likely to make a person into a
happy person to be honorable there is a
correlation there so it is some sort of
dispositional trait
that does connect with happiness but
notice that it connects up with a very
shifting
social world and we have to be very
careful not to confuse
honor by itself which could come from a
variety of sources with moral goodness
or being on track
motivated this is an interesting one
this is kind of a workplace reflection i
would say
um but but it you know
it does fit happy people do tend to be
motivated to get things done to
accomplish things
optimistic that makes sense uh that's
another dispositional trait uh which
would be reflective of being a happy
person and conducted being a happy
person it has to do with the choices
that we have about how to interpret our
environment how to interpret events how
to interpret
ongoing relationships
peaceful
this is another interesting one i i
think that you could make a good case
for this particularly if you're coming
from a
religious tradition and talking about
happiness because
very often happiness or beatitude or
blessedness or however you want to frame
it
is connected with peacefulness a
non-contentiousness
a seeking the good of others
and then there's some more that i think
are a little bit more ephemeral
enthusiasm enthusiasm by its nature
nobody wants to be around somebody who's
enthusiastic all the time because that's
forced and weird
but to be able to get enthusiastic about
things to get excited about not only
your own stuff but other people's stuff
what's going on around you
that's a reflection of happiness i think
lively
okay that's interesting i'm not sure
quite what to make of that one so i
leave that to other people's
conversation playful
you know
there's an old sort of adage in in
psychoanalysis how do you tell if
somebody's actually
been not cured but you know they've
gotten their life back together they can
work
we all have to work right
love
and play
play is very important not only for
children but also for adults
being playful being able to not be
serious all the time doesn't mean that
the person is joking around all the time
but the
be you know playful some of the time be
willing to to engage in non-serious
pursuits that is that is a quality i
think that does conduce to one's own
happiness and that of others
now let's talk about the category
of activities and here we were you know
we're dealing with this paradox when
we're thinking about these are types of
happiness how are they types of
happiness because they lead to it or
because they're reflective of it or
they're they're produced by it and i
think that a lot of in a lot of these
cases it's a uh
both end
so celebrate
celebration
uh when it's genuine celebration when
there's actually something to celebrate
and you're not doing it all the time and
it's not just because it's wednesday
and you want to have a drink or
something like that
uh real celebration is okay that i see
that could be a type of happiness
giving
this is a hard one for a lot of people
um is giving likely to make you happy it
can certainly make other people happy
those who you give to although it might
not make them happy they may they may
say i don't like your your charity you
know who are you to give me this
but the act of giving to other people of
extending yourself to other people even
just being available to other people
that opens up a sort of
realm of possibility within which we can
we can find ourselves growing developing
and becoming happier people
help
much along the same lines what's the
difference between giving and health i
guess you would say that help is when
people actually have some sort of
visible need that you can look at and
say
this needs to be addressed
humor
now that's an interesting one
when we're talking about humor we're not
just talking about playfulness but
joking
now some humor is very bad spirited
and can make people very unhappy think
about the humor that goes into bullying
and you might say well that's not
genuine humor and we can have a whole
conversation about that
but there is something to you know the
advice to find something to laugh about
each day i i try to practice that myself
i'm pretty fortunate that i can laugh at
a lot of things
uh including myself so i usually have
some good material i also have some
friends who are quite funny people so
i'm in good stead that way
kindness kindness is along the same
lines of giving or help
i think we could we could differentiate
them but we don't need to they're all in
the same basic circle and then there's
this category social i'm not sure what
exactly they meant by it perhaps they
meant have social interactions with
other people and that will be
conducive to or a component of your own
happiness and their happiness perhaps
even the happiness of other people i
think for example about you know when
somebody says to somebody else you can
come here and get him we need to get him
out of the house
we want to make him happy you're also
making that other person happy as well
so those are activities
now we come to a smaller group that i
just labeled things that happened to a
person rather than really being
products of their their own work um
two of these fit here very well one of
them i'm not quite sure about so let's
start with the one first that's
satisfaction
and
you could say satisfaction
and content we're really talking about
the same thing using slightly different
language but usually when we think about
satisfaction we think about
more specific things i am satisfied with
my job performance i am satisfied with
my my choice of
marriage partner which i am by the way
i am not satisfied with the fact that
i'm i'm overweight i am satisfied with
the steps that i'm taking to to work on
that um
is this something that
results from our own efforts or are we
satisfied and it's more something that
happens to us that's something to think
about the other two
blessed
and inspired these are not things that
you can produce in yourselves if the
words really mean what they're supposed
to mean
you can't make yourself blessed
that's a gratuitous gift
inspired i would say is along the same
lines it's kind of
there's a kind of weirdness to somebody
sort of inspiring themselves or making
themselves inspired we get inspired by
other things and their effects on us
they're unpredictable
excessive going beyond the normal
boundaries effects on us so those are
those are other ones and then there's
two that i left till the very end
one of these is spiritual spiritual is
one of those terms that really could be
all sorts of things all over the map but
i think that my in my view there really
is a strong connection between
spirituality and i by that i don't mean
spiritual not religious i think that
much of spirituality uh has been
developed through religion i'm not
saying that the two things are identical
but um you know great spiritual
practices many of them came out of the
matrices of religious belief but also
religious life and religious community
and so happiness is something that they
are concerned with what does it take to
actually be happy what is the nature of
happiness how do i attain it and a lot
of these other things you're going to
see being given as advice you want to be
happy give to other people that's that's
something that you can find in buddhism
christianity judaism all across the
map
and then the last one that i'm going to
close on happiness one of the types of
happiness
that they talk about in this 31 types is
love
now love is such a grand term i actually
you know spent an entire semester with
my students you can see the videos on
that in intro to philosophy just
exploring what's the nature of love and
friendship
and those sorts of things because love
means a lot of different things
oftentimes we associate it with loving
kindness or the love between you know
parents and children or we associate
with romantic love and you know which is
really a lot a lot of cases infatuation
and can all these things make us happy
yeah they can also make us miserable
but
when love really does exist when love is
properly oriented here i'm going to
start sounding like saint augustine
it is going to conduce to happiness and
it is great to not only be
a producer of happiness it's going to be
one of the
the ways happiness occurs you might
think of it as providing
the very flesh that happiness has as a
body incarnate so those that's my
reflections as a philosopher on the 31
types of happiness i hope that you
actually
get something out of this that that you
enjoy this video but also that you
really devote yourself to trying to make
yourself have a happier life during this
happiness happens month because that
seems to be you know the main thrust of
it i i focus on these issues myself
because of doing ethics i think that it
would be a great thing for people to be
thinking about this year round but
during this month in particular
we're trying to make happiness happen